hola en la última presentación lo que
hicimos fue redefinir las funciones se
no coste no hay tangente dijimos que si
teníamos un círculo unitario como este y
nuestro ángulo teta está que nuestro
ángulo teta es el ángulo entre el eje de
las equis y un radio entonces en el
círculo unitario este es nuestro radio y
este punto de intersección su coordenada
la coordenada donde el punto intersecta
el círculo unitario digamos que es x con
mayer entonces este punto es x con mayer
ahora nuestra nueva definición de de
funciones trigonométricas es que el seno
de teta es igual a la coordenada jr
esta es la coordenada de donde
intersecta el círculo unitario y también
recuerda que bueno esto no es cualquier
círculo de hecho es el círculo unitario
su radio tiene es de radio 1 así que
coseno de tetas la coordenada x y seno
de teta es la coordenada jr
entonces también también dijimos lo
siguiente que tangente de teta
es igual al cateto opuesto sobre cateto
adyacente es lo mismo lo mismo que es
sobre equis y eso es eso entonces bueno
eso es bastante interesante porque bueno
eso es igual a seno de theta sobrecoste
no detecta sido si te fijas bien porque
éste no es igual a jeyko seno de teta es
igual a equis entonces piensa en eso
porque bueno no es casualidad y con eso
ya sobre la mesa
vamos a intentar ver cómo como eso
define a estas funciones iniciemos con
la función seno podemos intentar
graficar la voy a poner aquí una pequeña
tabla baja entonces vamos a hacer eso
pongo dos columnas en una van los
valores para theta y en otros valores
para seno de tan así que ok bueno
iniciamos cuando teta es igual a 00
radiales cuánto vale seno de teta así
que cuando t t es igual a 0 el radio el
radio mira de hecho ésta está aquí el
radio y el punto de intersección con el
círculo unitario y ese punto tiene
coordenadas
0 y si esa es la coordenada donde
intersecta el círculo unitario entonces
seno de teta que es la coordenada ayer
que corresponde a la coordenada y el
seno de teta es igual a 0 ajá entonces
aquí es 0 y si pensamos en que el cual
es el seno de teta cuando theta vale el
pi medios entonces sigue pi medios en pi
medios en este caso nuestro radio es
este radio interceptamos al círculo
unitario aquí en este punto el punto 0.1
y eso que nos dice que nos dice veamos
la coordenada y en este caso es 1 y
ahora cuando teta es igual a pick-up
irradian es entonces el pi radian es
interceptamos al círculo unitario
justamente aquí llegamos a pi radiales y
tierra destinada coordenada menos 10
cierto ajá entonces menos 10 a
intercepta el círculo unitario y cuál es
la coordenada y en este caso cuánto vale
es cero ahí lo puedes ver es cero
entonces seno de pie es igual a cero y
bueno sigamos recorriendo el círculo
unitario cuando el ángulo o teta es
igual a tres piso sobre 43 pies sobre 4
de hecho eso está mal está bien hecho
está mal estoy muy mal
lo siento aquí es 3 pi sobre 2 porque
aquí sería aquí es 3 pi sobre 2 lo
siento ok entonces en 3 piso sobre dos
en teta igual a 3 piso sobre 2 cuánto
vale seno de teta intersecta el zinc
comunitario en este punto cero como
menos 1 así que el seno de teta es igual
a menos 1 en este caso y ahora sigamos
recorriendo todo el círculo y llegamos a
2 y radiales y bueno aquí puedes ver que
regresamos al punto de partida al punto
inicial así que ese no detecta en teta
igual a 20 de teta esa hora cero una vez
más 0 y ahora graphic hemos estos puntos
aquí vamos a graficar esto y después
vamos a intentar ver cómo cómo se ven
los puntos que hay en medio
y te mostraré cómo se ve la curva para
la función seno entonces voy a dibujar
los ejes este es el eje de las x
ahora el eje de las 10 así lo hago lo
mejor posible porque bueno no sé la
mejor artista pero ok ahí está el eje de
las yes y este es el el eje de las equis
pero bueno esta vez esta vez en lugar de
decir que es el eje de las equis lo voy
a llamar el el eje de teta entonces este
será el eje que va bueno porque estamos
tomando valores de teta cierto entonces
aquí va teta y ahora vamos a graficar la
función seno de teta dijimos que cuando
te dará igual a cero que pasa seno de
teta es igual a cero en este punto en
este caso es el punto 0,0 ahora cuando
teta es igual a pi sobre 20 de teta es
igual a 1
así que aún no es el punto y sobre dos y
sobre 21 y cuando te desigual api seno
de teta es igual a cero otra vez así que
este es el punto piso pico más cero y
ahora ok cuando teta es igual a tres
pisos sobre cuatro ya los trajes'
extendido tres pisos de cuatro a tres
piso sobre dos a tres piso sobre dos
seno de teta lo escribo aquí se no
detecta en 3 piso sobre 2 es igual a
menos 1 baja a menos uno es interesante
eso ahora cuando te desigualdad 2 p seno
de teta es igual a cero
y sabemos que estos puntos están en la
gráfica deseo de teta y si intentamos e
intentamos graficar los valores entre
entre los valores que ya vimos lo que
tenemos aquí puede usar de hecho
triángulos 30 60 90 o usar el teorema de
pitágoras para calcular estos puntos que
de hecho es un es un ejercicio
interesante lo puedes hacer pero tienes
una gráfica una gráfica es que una
gráfica que se vea algo así algo así
después baja y otra vez sube y bueno
ahora tienes de hecho quizás ya lo hayas
visto antes es una onda senoidal y si
pones tetas menores que cero
la onda senoidal seguirá seguirá seguirá
por siempre en ambas direcciones y
seguirá y seguirá oscilando entre los
valores de menos 1 y 1 ajá entonces
siempre siempre seguirá eso es lo
interesante de esto y bueno esa es la
gráfica de la función seno ahora en el
siguiente módulo te quiero mostrar la
gráfica de la función coseno
y bueno relax relacionar estas funciones
ajá y como como pueden describir a
tantas cosas a tantas cosas que oscilan
en el mundo es algo interesante y
sorprendente
yo que sé pero pero bueno quiero
mostrarte cómo relacionan cómo se
relacionan con frecuencia y amplitud eso
es importante así que nos vemos y ahora
sólo por diversión sólo por diversión
intenta graficar la función coseno y la
función tangente también por qué no así
que diviértete nos vemos pronto